ich zitiere jetzt direkt mal aus dem
buche baerbock unter herr sprach siehe
den grünen geht es zu gut so wenig ihnen
eine plage schicken um sie zu prüfen und
die plage nannte er palma boris palmer
eigentlich nur bürgermeister von fucking
tübingen aber öfter im fernsehen als joe
biden und dafür braucht nur sein handy
die vorgeschichte kennen sie bestimmt
irgendwelche ex-fußballer posten oder
sagen eklige sachen fliegen irgendwo
raus und dann kommt boris palmer und
postet doch was viel viel blöder riss
unter anderem ein hässliches wort mit
das zivilisierte medien vor echte
herausforderungen stellt der euro ist
ein schlimmer rassist hat frauen seien
angeboten hat frauen seien angeboten
seinen punkt punkt punkt schwanz
angeboten einen rassistisch obszönen
begriff für dessen geschlechtsteil hat
frauen seinen schwanz angeboten schwanz
darf man sagen ja großes rätsel jetzt
welche debatte wollte boris palmer hier
genau anstoßen
ja tatsache ist er zitiert einen
facebook kommentar von einem fake
account in dem ohne jeden beweis
behauptet wird der frühere
nationalspieler aogo aber für sich
selbst mal einen rassistischen begriff
benutzt ein wort das man weder zitieren
noch überhaupt sagen sollte also wenn
überhaupt dann musst du so elegant
machen wie diese deutsche ski legende
einer der bekanntesten politiker in
deutschland tut man so was nicht ganz
einfach und da muss auch letztlich
irgendwann konsequenzen weist über sein
justus maria jesus maria herr neureuther
anstieg miko bringt frist dann auch
nichts
gut gemeint ist boris palmer rassist
keine ahnung wahrscheinlich nicht in
jedem fall ist ein wahnsinnig
anstrengender egomane und besserwisser
sei kein zufall dass er den neuesten
idioten post genau einen tag vor dem
grünen-parteitag in seinem
heimatbundesland raushaut der mann ist
und bleibt ein aufmerksamkeit junkie
oder auf tübingen gehört nicht widerlegt
wurde
wenn server das ist wohl dieses spiel
und das wichtigste anliegen von parma
ist immer per deswegen alle paar wochen
die nächste mega provokation dann fühlte
sich wieder total missverstanden und so
weiter und so weiter
ein perpetuum mobile des geistigen
dünnschiss gibt es da nicht was von
ratio farben natürlich poster gut forte
endlich weniger posten müssen einmal
behauptet natürlich wie immer erkämpft
mich für sich sondern für die offene
debatte gegen die sie ahnen es verdammte
kämpfen culture der boris sagt allen
ernstes ich zitiere ich kann und will
nicht widerrufen ist er jetzt luther
oder was nach einem schwanz post
ich kann echt und existenzvernichtung
wegen angeblich falscher niemals
akzeptieren
das beschert bekam der liberalen
demokratie eben wenn man nicht mal mehr
endpunkt schwanz schreiben kann dann
leben wir alle in der diktatur
darunter macht das nicht zum millionsten
mal man darf hier alles sagen und muss
anschließend damit leben was andere dazu
meinen ja im internet tagen rund um die
uhr super woche schnellgerichte und
fällen über moralische urteile aber
dagegen hilft ein einfaches mittel
ignorieren ja zum beispiel nicht bei
twitter seien das geht im übrigen ist
boris palmer doch der lebende
gegenbeweis für cancel kaltschaum und
fühle mich mundtot machen ach ja
deshalb sitzt er wohl ständig bei
[Musik]
bei maischberger im bayerischen rundfunk
im swr
bei n-tv und bei markus lanz haupter so
oft da müsste eigentlich längst miete
zahlen
der lauteste mund tote aller zeiten wo
es palm an die einzige sendung und er
noch nicht wahr ist murmeln ihr bei rtl
und dann beruft er sich bei schwarzgeld
auch noch auf ironie dabei weiß jeder
ironie in der politik funktioniert nicht
meine fresse wie oft ist das schon in
die hose gegangen
die top 3 der schlimmsten ironie
versuche deutscher politiker ja die
mittel ja die möglichkeiten aus den
neuen bundesländern in drei vier fünf
jahren blühende landschaften zu machen
haben die rente ist sicher
ich finde das eine sehr gute arbeit oder
damals als genscher auf dem balkon in
prag diesen ironischen geld mit der
ausreise gemacht hat sind alle
rübergekommen
doch zurück zu boris palmer das
parteiausschlussverfahren gegen ihn ist
ein fehler
dauert vielleicht jahre und bietet
direkt die nächste bühne für die
opferrolle
die grünen sollen den mann einfach
ertragen auch wenn es bei so viel
arroganz natürlich manchmal schwerfällt
diese erfahrungen und überlegungen
führen mich dazu fahrverbote für
dieselfahrzeuge in deutschen städten für
untauglich und unverhältnismäßig zu
halten
und da werden jetzt nicht alle meiner
parteifreunde begeistert sein
aha da werden sie wieder schön ab kotzen
die müslis wie er das genießt er genießt
es ist eine rolle im grunde tragisch
boris palmer ist ein großes politisches
talent und ein sehr guter lokalpolitiker
aber was mich wirklich ärgert er
verkauft seinen jüngsten ausfall auch
noch ohne rot zu werden als satire
satire also irgendwann ist auch mal
schluss
der deutsche tierschutzbund stellt klar
das muss jetzt nicht mal aufhören dass
alle sich mit satire rausreden es gibt
keinen satirischen kontext in dem sich
das wort schwanz sinnvoll verwenden
lässt merkte dass du möge man kann sich
auch nicht ironisch auf den
behindertenparkplatz stellen oder den
hund satirisch auf den schulhof packen
lassen um auf die missstände im
bildungssystem hinzuweisen und im laden
was clown ist keine kapitalismuskritik
auch keine ironische deshalb schluss mit
der blöden satire ausrede wir dürfen das
nicht
ja ein echtes dilemma was sollten die
grünen jetzt machen mit ihrem problem
boris ich lade die frage man direkt
weiter in einen anderen gelernten
querulanten an gernot hassknecht ja
gerne und was tun ja was wohl die sollen
sich freuen
diese glattgebügelte manufactum partei
muss froh sein über jeden trennten den
sie noch hat und wenn es nur die
nervensäge palma ist so verzweifelt bin
ich inzwischen schon früher ist man als
nervensäge zu den grünen gegangen um
sich mit anderen nervensägen zu streiten
das war der ganze witz ich sage nur
jutta ditfurth dort hat die genervt
claudia roth ist die mir auf den sack in
einem wunderbar dass und heute
[Musik]
unerträglich anna lena und rupert haben
die k-frage ohne streit gelöst
ja weil ihr eine kreuzung sei tauss'
streichelzoo und scientology hier grüne
damals der zustand der bundes partei
entschuldigt dieses wort ist extrem
beschissen beschissen großartig und
grüne heute
hallo liebe freundinnen und freunde
[Applaus]
da kommt mir direkt die harmonies hose
hoch und warum sehen wie alle so gut aus
die frühen grünen hättest du gar nicht
in hd zeigen können da wäre der
fernseher explodiert verstehe ist ihnen
alles zu harmonisch und deswegen muss ab
und zu einer was über schwänze posten ja
nein völlig egal über was hauptsache es
wird gestritten streiten ist die essenz
der demokratie stattdessen verabschieden
die einen high tea time programmentwurf
wo für jeden was dabei ist also außer
für leute die rechnen können und selbst
einen artikel wie deutschland alles ist
drin finden an manchen grünen noch zu
kontrovers über 300 mitglieder wollen
das wort deutschland streichen kann man
machen aber dann bitte auch die grünen
schließt zu viel aus müssen wir ändern
in bündnis 90 eine farbe ihrer wahl
natürlich geht es boris palmer immer nur
um boris palmer aber wenn sich die wahl
jungen grünen endlich mal wieder zoffen
ertrag ich sogar den twitter tourette
könig aus tübingen nur stimmt da ist
sogar was dran was sie dürfen jedoch
nicht zustimmen
das ist das schlimmste was man einem
querulanten antun kann
sie müssen sagen solche meinungen haben
in der heute-show keinen platz ich aber
bin ich gar nicht du sollst mich zwei
jahren du hast ja ok sie sind gefeuert
das war ja klar wenzel kann man das hier
nichts mehr sagen
hallo youtube unten könnt ihr den kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
infobox
neben mir gibt es weitere interessante
videos verlinkungen komma vielen dank
[Musik]